[Music]
let's go to jack in indianapolis what's
up jack
hey dr john thanks for taking my call
you got it brother what's up
so i really need your help with
something um my question for you today
is how can i support my girlfriend with
an eating disorder specifically she has
uh bulimia okay and um we've been dating
for about nine months i'm 30 years old
she's 26
and she's loved my life i can't see a
future without her i want her to be my
wife future mother my kids and as we've
grown closer together
i learned that she suffered with an
eating disorder for about six years
throughout high school and college and
um
you know she's done inpatient and
outpatient treatment
but i've noticed some evidence lately
that
she's been binging and purging
what's the
evidence um so
specifically one night
she had overeaten
like a lot and
she went to the bathroom for a while and
she came out and her eyes were
really wet and there were like food
particles in the toilet okay and you
know i i it took me a second to realize
what that was
and then
my mind started looking back at things
in the past like oh she canceled several
of our dates like we had plans i wonder
if she's staying home to binge and purge
um
you know things like that there's i'm
kind of like looking at things that have
happened in the past and saying okay
there was evidence there for the eating
disorder and i just missed it okay or
maybe i didn't want to see it
and so now my mind is spiraling i'm kind
of projecting into the future like what
happens when she gets pregnant is that
gonna
impact
you know her body image and
exacerbates the eating disorder um
you know when when she goes to grad
school this fall is the stress of that
going to cause the eating disorder to
flare up
yeah and and she doesn't know that i
know
that i that i've seen this evidence and
i just i don't know how to talk to her
about it
i want to treat her with dignity and
respect because i've suffered with
addiction too yeah um
i just i don't know what my role is
awesome well um
and your heart's gold brother and
that's hard
that one's hard
um but thank you for the call and man
this is such a huge deal i think it's
important for me to just tell you
um
there are some stone cold experts in
this field and i'm not one of them okay
um
here's what i know about
most people don't know that anorexia
up until recently with the opioid stuff
and it may still be it may be neck and
neck
the single uh most lethal mental health
issue was anorexia eating disorders
um
bulimia i think is a the stats are a bit
different um and somebody will correct
me if i'm wrong um they send me a note
here but
um
it really beats up your body
one of the cornerstones of bulimia is
shame
yes right and so the secret part
a doesn't surprise me at all and b
that feeds the machine
the secrets okay
and so the greatest gift you can give
her
is in a
in a season tell her what you just told
me
really you did a great job i love you i
see no future of mine without you in it
and
i have a past
i've struggled from addiction
you have um been so vulnerable and brave
telling me about your past struggles
with um
purging
and i noticed it happen again
yeah how are you and we start there
and here's a couple of hard hard truths
here number one you can't heal her
number two you're going to want to look
for evidence of this everywhere and i
would recommend you not do that
okay okay she may have missed dates
because she had other things going on or
she had covet or she had the like who
knows what you know of this one time and
maybe two or three other times you're
not telling me about but um
often we'll start to play beautiful mind
and we'll start like oh yeah and then
and then and then right and all of a
sudden we're on a youtube channel with
our conspiracy theory right
when it comes to relationships i would
just turn the light on on this one it's
hard
um
some studies show up to 50 of people who
struggle bulimia have a history of
anxiety
um the idea that it's all body image is
more media fabrication than reality
there's a mix of genetics here there's a
mix of um
anxiety there's even some some new stuff
out that it might be a metabolic issue
that a body just has a i don't really
know how to describe it but
a body has a tendency to run lower than
um a
physio neural body would do so all i had
to say is it's a complex web of stuff um
and
you may need to go back to counseling
right well no i won't say may she
probably 100 needs to
a great gift you could give her is i
want to come with you would you be
willing to go and i'd like to join you
um
there would be a connectivity there that
would be awesome okay
and i love that idea this is such a open
to that okay here's the other thing she
may tell you you're i don't even know
what you're talking about how dare you i
can't believe you did this
and
here's one of these things to keep in
the back furthest reaches of your heart
okay
you may blow your relationship up and
save her life
okay
because she may tell you to go to hell
she may say screw this i'm not having
this conversation with you
okay and that will hurt more than
anything because you're coming to her
with an open heart and trying to look to
her future
um i would recommend
i'd stay away from like well what about
our unborn baby and what about i
wouldn't go down those roads okay those
are we're talking a couple years out
okay
um let's get to
i noticed some old patterns have shown
back up and i'm really scared and i've
been there too and i'm scared for you
i'm scared for us i'm scared for me
because i don't know how to love you
right now
but i see it and i'm willing to walk
alongside you because you and i have a
future together
um
but that starts with no more secrets
okay i love that idea okay
and hear me say this brother she is
lucky to have you
um
read less google okay
what's it called read less google don't
go
google this less is what i'm saying yes
i'm looking up every resource online
yeah i would do that much less i would
talk to a professional um who's got
experience working with um
women in disordered eating it's hard
it's hard
there's just so much going on so much
going on so much going on
um but again she's lucky to have you my
brother um
i'll say this out to everybody um
again i'm not an expert in this um
obviously working with
high school and college students for as
long as i did i've seen it so often
is very very hard so if you're
struggling with disorder eating
whether you are struggling with anorexia
and you're just not eating
you're binging and purging you're eating
too much
please reach out and call somebody
please reach out and call somebody and
if you love somebody who's struggling
from one of these three evil iterations
of disorder eating
hold somebody's hand look them in the
eye and say i love you
i love you enough to say i see
that you're not okay
i love you and it's not about it's not
about i need to tell you that you're
beautiful i mean it's not it's it's so
much more complex
tell somebody you love them and you're
willing to walk alongside
the hell that it's going to be
to get to healing the other side of this
thing